you have to be pretty top notch in your
profession just to survive it all
you get heavy turbulence you got to slow
the aircraft down because you could have
structural failure like losing a wing
wouldn't be much fun
a north atlantic storm in november it's
a pretty impressive event to put it
mildly
my name is
john raymond bourange i'm what you would
call a mercenary pilot
i fly for higher
to he who pays the most
i had 4
343 kilos of cocaine
and i was flying from colombia directly
to canada
normally the flight would be about nine
hours give or take
but i ran into the storm for about 45
minutes or an hour
before i broke out
and lo and behold there were the f-18s
then they were off to my beer
and the other guy came up close beside
us flying around me
they can signals to go down and i just
wave to them they can't shoot at you
but they were running out of gas
we were just timing and say okay how
long is it going to be before they're
going to run out
it was interesting he gave us a nice
little show
i went down to treetop level and flew
the rest of the way treetop level
[Music]
below radar so nobody knew where the
airplane was
the authorities put out an alert to all
the airports
there's a big white conveyor somewhere
in canada if anybody sought to report it
i should have arrived around six o'clock
in the morning but i arrived at quarter
to nine instead
[Music]
i was standing out on the runway waiting
for the crew hired to go and do the
pickup
we looked all over the place couldn't
figure out where the hell these guys
were
turns out they'd been there since three
in the morning at around 7 30 they
decided i wasn't coming and they left
so anyway i started walking and the
truck went by i hit strike and he gave
me a lift all the way down to the lumber
cam
and that's where i was when the rcmp
arrived by helicopter because the police
had blocked off all the roads
so they asked what's in the airplane i
said cocaine he says how much i says a
lot
it's being touted as the biggest drug
bust in canadian history and probably
the most dramatic
the seizure of 4
300 kilos of cocaine really reverberated
through dea
there's a staggering amount of cocaine
coupled with the fact that it was flown
directly from the north coast of
columbia into canada
[Music]
i would have made around 45 million
it's a pretty good payday
for one day's work that's not bad
[Music]
i was arrested
pled guilty and got 23 years
that was it and became famous
but i take things with a grain of salt
it was and i believe it still is the
biggest bust ever in canada
[Music]
you